I mean data mining is you get a lot of
information in a lot of raw data and you
want to get the nuggets of information
hence the word mining so the gold in the
data that's the data mining are usually
starts with people saying oh you can
load the data can you make some money
from this is there something interesting
in there that we haven't found ourselves
yet you tell us you the expert that's
usually starts so it might be big
companies or medical people doctors and
hospitals there might have lots of data
actually the first step usually is what
do you actually want to know from the
data
cuz people aren't always that clear but
actually after this is where it comes to
artificial intelligence so a lot of the
work that we do is actually applied
artificial intelligence so you get you
get your data and then how do you get a
pattern are you involves algorithms it
was programming it may be some
mathematical or statistical systems that
you want to design it might be more
artificial intelligence somehow using
something like evolutionary computation
or machine learning in the broadest
sense for example sometimes you get your
data and you know it just looks like
this is how long you study that this is
the grade you go to the exam
really obvious it's obviously clear
correlation perfect yes I mean this is
not very difficult and we can use them
some simple statistics videos that's
fine that's easy but then often so the
data you get doesn't quite look like
this it might look a bit more like it's
more messy like this and even in that
case you could probably still do some
statistics on it yeah and there's
probably some relationship it looks a
bit like this but it's getting a bit
more ambiguous now and it's not so
obvious anymore what is it and sort of
statistics may work it may not work
anymore things funny gets really
interesting use when the data starts
looking like something like this I'm
sort of exaggerating a little bit now
but you do statistics and it comes back
with almost no relationship because I
mean there's like a zero relationship
between things but obviously we you and
me look at it you've got up cough I
don't know what's going on here's a
football and it's clearly something in
this data something is going on here I
don't understand and and that's where
the artificial intelligence comes in
that's experienced we look at this meat
girl or something here how can we teach
the computer to get that out there is a
shape how do we get that shape out and
then of course the real problem is so
this is if it was just looking like this
it'd be easy to teach a computer of
course in reality it's so messy the data
can't do enough box on you ever
something like this and somewhere in
here there is this little pattern and
maybe it repeats in a few places but it
gets really hard to see you know how do
you teach a computer now to get this
pattern out and of course remember you
don't know what it looks like the
pattern you're looking for the unknown
if you know what you're looking for I'd
be easy that's what Google does actually
Google is easy job because they have a
huge database it's just a lookup table
we don't have that we don't actually
know what the thing looks like so you
need to find something you don't know
what it looks like it's somewhere hiding
in there maybe it isn't right in the how
do we do it that's data mining really
from this stage there is lots of
different steps I mean the first thing
we usually do when we get data and it
doesn't look as simple as the original
form to do something called
pre-processing of the data we make it in
a nicer shape maybe we bring it on a
certain scale we're actually trying to
plot the date I'm just looking at it
plotting it one way floating is another
way to dimensions three dimensions
maybe we can eliminate some of the
variables because they turn out
irrelevant or maybe lots of information
is missing so we can't use them
sometimes also the data is not always
numbers it might be text that might be
pictures and then how do we put out in
so there's all this sort of messing
around in the beginning with today to
bring in some sort of okay some sort of
shaping it's saying we can look at it
more easier yeah and of course the
problem with that is is it really noisy
so it may be the noisy bit it's the
really interesting bit in the data you
know when you get your day turn it's
like lots of data is like this and then
your phone is there and now of course
the question is well okay maybe that's
why your sensor failed maybe the person
didn't fill in the questionnaire
properly or maybe that's actually the
one data point that's really interesting
that's where you can make your money and
that's part of the question it's an
outlier which is something we need to
get rid of or is it actually the one
interesting pattern that makes you the
money or the person that needs to drive
or whatever whatever the question is
have you looking for statistics a
would-be statistics and go back to my
picture it would be statistics in a
divorce like this and we can do things
which are quite simple and even in the
machine learning we still do some
statistics but statistics are not on its
own it's not enough has too many
limitations so we need to go beyond
statistics and that's where computer
programming is really good because it's
more flexible than sistex we can deal
with text we can deal with pictures I
mean to come to statistics and pictures
doesn't work you can't do statistics on
text we can do a pattern
alphabet P can do a path of mining on a
picture we can do an image recognition
we can mix all these things together we
can also deal then a lot of information
is missing I mean usually when you get
these big data sets I mean this is one
of the myths big data people think I so
huge data and so you know no problem
but of course big data usually also
means a lot of data is missing a lot of
data is messy the data isn't always
clean and the bigger the data gets this
problem doesn't get any smaller gets
bigger as well so statistics usually
can't cope window is missing values or
when it is missing the data because he
has some very fundamental requirements
so for computer science we can deal with
this missing data okay we write a bit of
code that deals with missing data the
data test may say we write a bit of code
that does something massages the data or
I don't know whatever it is so that's
where very much more flexible than
statistics statistics is very powerful
than it works but when it doesn't work
then computer science what is it
correlation does not imply causation the
idea in layman's terms that just because
you see it happen doesn't mean it's like
you know only because you're carrying an
umbrella sand doesn't mean it's gonna
rain today right
I mean exactly you observe things
together but what you don't know is well
today I actually was a related to B is
being related to a or maybe and usually
actually there's another reason
underlying it all together which is
what's happening I mean the lot of
medical work we do it this is this is
interesting so we were looking at
patients taking certain drugs and we
want to know whether the drug is really
helping them or not and then after
they've taken the drug something might
happen to them something something you
don't want maybe they have a heart
attack and the question of course is
well what's it a drug that caused the
heart attack or was it something else
and it's fundamentally important to
understand that you can't just conclude
only because they took a drug that's why
the harder that usually it's not at all
because of the drugs actly it's
something called co-founding in
technical terms there's lots of
co-founding issues and you need to
understand the difference between them
you will have heard of days it's always
in the newspaper every year again
anything sold this bad for you why is
eating sold bad for you because it
apparently causes high blood pressure
where's the evidence for this so what
happens is I looked at this in 1988
there was some studies on this and this
is what this picture shows and it's
something
British Medical Journal where we were
looking at different countries and you
were looking at basically urine in salt
and what's happened is each of these
thoughts is a different population ie a
different country and they measured are
the thousands of people in the urine how
much salt there was and they also
measured a blood pressure and this is
the graph so you got this how much sold
this is how much blood pressure and you
can see there's a sort of slight
positive correlation there and is
actually based on this study or it's
kind of a meta study that the conclusion
was okay so more salt must lead to
higher blood pressure however actually
if you look at this picture properly you
might see that weight the moment there's
lots of point here and I saw four four
over there and I look a bit strange and
actually if you were to remove those
four points from the analysis your trend
would suddenly become negative it's only
because of these that the trend is
positive it turns out that these
outliers are from countries were sold
isn't very popular in the died sort of
non industrialized countries in in
Africa so okay actually is it possible
but this study is flawed this data
should never have been included because
it's not what we are used to invest on
society and if you look at ours actually
thinks all this good for you because it
seems just like to reduce blood pressure
there has been more work since
understand that probably is a link
between salt and blood pressure but it's
not as obvious and there may be much
more going on and actually what hasn't
been established at all is but a
slightly raised blood pressure might
actually be good for you because it
might also help you in other ways the
interpretation the invitation of it and
getting the right you know rubbish in
rubbish out actually making sure that
what you what you put in make sense and
and yes think thinking of the
co-founding things if you use data that
you shouldn't have used because it's on
one country which is completely
different for example like here it
doesn't it doesn't help
JPG works by down stopping the car
components and using other techniques as
well the majority of video compression
methods will do the same thing so you're
being compressed right now I certainly
am yes